[Music]
foreign
crime daily new details are emerging a
week after The Disappearance of a
California family including an
eight-month-old baby were found murdered
two men are now in custody charging
connection to the kidnapping and murder
of the dairy family officials say Jesus
Elgato were kidnapped then murdered the
family of four including an
eight-month-old her mother and father
and her uncle a Manhunt ensued after
authorities found a truck belonging to
the family on fire days later the
victim's bodies were discovered by a
farmer in an almond Orchard please say
Salgado was a former employee of the
family's trucking business and had a
long-standing feud going with them their
kidnapping was reportedly caught on
surveillance video outside the business
showing an armed man forcing the family
into a truck Alberto Salgado Jesus's
brother was arrested later on suspicion
that he helped destroy evidence he is
charged with criminal conspiracy and
accessory
our recap continues in California taking
us to Los Angeles where disgrace movie
Mogul Harvey Weinstein faces another
stint in court off the back of the metoo
movement
Weinstein faced his four counts of rape
and seven other sexual assault charges
in connection to five women all of whom
pled planned to testify as Jane does for
the prosecution Weinstein is already
serving 23 years in prison for similar
charges in New York after his conviction
back in February of 2020 with an appeal
on this case in the works a conviction
in the LA case could be the proverbial
nail in the coffin on Monday news broke
that Jennifer siebel Newsom wife of
California governor Gavin Newsom will
testify in the trial against Weinstein
in a statement siebel newsom's attorney
said quote my client was sexually
assaulted by Harvey Weinstein out of
purported business meeting that turned
out to be a trap jury selection is
slated to last two weeks and the trial
itself is expected to run eight weeks
Philip allegations of rape from The Last
Five Years convicted in similar crimes
uh two years ago in New York now how do
you think the defense will work to try
to get an impartial jury in this La case
well the first thing I hope they'll do
and something that I do is I send a law
clerk out in the hall while the the
veneer men are assembling to see what
they're reading you know if you have
people out there reading you know Jane
Eyre Little Women and Nancy Drew you
want to kick them because they're going
to be more friendly toward women you
also want to get rid of people who are
reading stuff like you know Helter
Skelter Mein Kampf and To Kill a
Mockingbird you don't want them and as
you're doing your examination of those
jurors you want to find out especially
with the women uh what organizations
they might belong to or donate money to
like women's live movement the National
Organization for Women
Etc and you want to obviously get rid of
those because of the inherent bias now
the one thing Harvey does have for him
is that home field advantage what better
place for a Hollywood Mogul to stand
trial is in Hollywood itself just about
all the veneer men I shouldn't say all
but a big percentage of them are
employed by the biz and I think there's
a cultural understanding In The Biz that
part of the employment package is that
people behind the camera in front of the
camera expect these types of antics now
real quick Terry siebel news and
testifying good thing or bad thing for
the prosecution oh it's definitely a
good thing for the prosecution very
liberal LA area and she is deemed
obviously a stature in her community so
I think it's good for the prosecution
well thank you for joining us here on
lawn crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss Justice in America
[Music]
thank you